tiffany's in dallas hi tiffany welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi how are you great how can we help
um so i was calling because i um
i recently got married well not recently
it'll be a year in november
and um my husband and i we were
um well i thought we were on board to
um follow the the plan i actually went
through your class um
a couple years ago and so i was telling
my husband about it and
she seemed excited initially um
but um i guess maybe after a few months
of being married
we uh we had joint bank accounts and
then he decided he wanted to
have separate bank accounts and in that
time when we had the joint bank account
um we did pay off
a few of our um credit cards that we had
separately and
student loans and so now we
we haven't had that conversation
anymore it was just kind of like i'm i'm
not sure
it was kind of like an abrupt decision
no he had the conversation he just went
and did it why haven't you said that's
not okay
well i i did and um
he just kind of implied that he he
didn't want to have separate
or he just said he didn't want to have
separate account he wanted to have a
separate account
why um
well he said he didn't like the way i
was spending money
and when i brought close attention that
you know we
paid off student loans we paid off
credit cards
weren't the two of you working together
on a budget no you weren't
um we did a couple times no you weren't
because you were spending money and he
didn't like how you're spending money
and because you guys didn't have a plan
where you're working together
yeah hey tiffany this doesn't feel like
a big deal but i want you to sound
every alarm you have this is a big deal
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today's money fights and money
problems
jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is he just took his treasure
and took it away from you and set it
over to the side and cut you out
right this is dangerous relationship
ground
this is stop the presses get somebody
that you trust in your life that can sit
down with the both of you
and you'd have this conversation like
today or good pastor good marriage
counselor somebody to walk you guys
through this and you combine
your lives for richer for poorer in
sickness and in health unto thee all my
worldly goods
i pledge that's the old-fashioned
marriage vows that no one says anymore
because it caught the combining of your
lives and the combining of your assets
and the combining of your spending
decisions
causes the combining of your values and
forces
detailed in-depth communication and
there's a lot of
thrashing around going on at your house
where he just
jerks stuff away and then you stand
there looking like a deer in the
headlights going what happened
because you were over here overspending
or you were spending money
and he couldn't control you or some kind
of crap is going on here i don't know
what it is
but i smell stink something's not right
somebody's heart's not
settled to year end whether it's yours
or his or both but this is a giant
red neon flashing light saying danger
danger and you gotta address it soon
and dress it with a good heart if you
come in and say hey these two
knuckleheads on the radio said that you
got a divorce yeah don't do that
that's not what we're saying but we are
saying if you don't fix this when you're
30 it's
you know 10 years from now this will
have gotten much worse it's not going to
naturally get better systems left to
themselves deteriorate
unless you put pressure on them to
polish and to become and marriage is a
system in that regard
so um we've i've seen this for 30 years
coaching couples
it's a very very dangerous sign so yeah
you guys need to get on the same page he
is
uh either controlling or he's ultimately
disgusted with you or
both over the handling of money and you
guys need to get on the same page so
we'll help
you guys sit down with a good marriage
counselor get some coaching before this
gets worse
it's not a lightweight thing and then
i'll give you
ramsey plus and you guys get in there
and go through
uh go through financial peace university
get on the every dollar
budget together and combine your
finances and come into agreement
every month before the month begins as
to where our spending is going to occur
and you both have a vote
he doesn't have the only vote and
neither do you
and neither do you this is called
marriage we're gonna work together we're
gonna compromise
for the good of the couple and uh you've
you surrender yourself
he surrenders himself for the good of
the pair
and so what i do when sharon and i are
looking at this okay what's good for the
two of us
not what's not what do i want and i
double up don't double up my fists and
have a
fit like a four-year-old kid on the
cereal aisle it happened yesterday at my
house i said hey let's
let's start putting some money in
savings here instead of
just putting money over here my wife
said i don't feel comfortable with that
what if we split the difference
and i trust her and she trusts me and
she was wise
and i wasn't being unwise i just had an
idea in my head and together we made a
good decision and now we're on the same
page moving forward
that's it this is how it works